para el análisis nuestro invitado de
esta mañana es el politólogo y
periodista colombiano ariel ávila
subdirector del centro de pensamiento
sobre el conflicto armado paz y
posconflicto ariel gracias
buenos días se se ha hablado mucho de
brutalidad policial en las protestas
pero también de actos de violencia por
parte de la ciudadanía como ponderan
usted es el grado de los ataques y de
los daños que vimos en esta semana
buenos días y muy amable por su
invitación mire tres respuestas lo
primero es que el 99% de los
manifestantes lo hacen pacíficamente en
la mañana en la tarde todo es pacífico
los temas de violencia comienzan después
de las seis o siete de la noche 2 hasta
el momento tenemos según organizaciones
sociales 31 homicidios el estado tiene
un poco más o menos la cifra de
corroboración pero tan se también la
defensoría al pueblo habla de 87
desaparecidos de esos 31 homicidios 30
son civiles menores jóvenes varios
menores de edad y uno es un policía
entonces hay un hay un abuso policial
muy grande y esto está llevando a que la
gente cada vez salga con más violencia a
la calle tanto naciones unidas como la
oea se manifestaron en contra del abuso
policial y lo tercero es que hoy hoy
sabemos si esto se desactiva o se vuelve
a activar o se impulsa aún más hoy está
convocado el gran paro la gran marcha
desde las 9 de la mañana y vamos a ver
cuáles son los niveles de movilización
ahí sabremos el futuro de esto
mire el presidente de duke llamó al
diálogo pero los miembros de los
partidos de la oposición dijeron que no
se reunirán con el mandatario hasta que
se retiren los militares de las ciudades
en que terminó por ejemplo en la mesa de
diálogo después de los paros de 2019 y
con este panorama cómo ve usted lo que
se pueda lograr con esta nueva mesa
es muy difícil que la que alguien se
siente a dialogar con el presidente
eduqué en este momento por dos razones
primero porque no cumplió nada en el
diálogo nacional del 2019 2020 todo fue
para dilatar el tiempo esto es volver a
cometer ese error por organizaciones o
saliendo lo van a hacer pero lo segundo
es que en este momento están rotas
varias garantías constitucionales en el
país hay tanques y tanquetas en las
calles por mi casa pasa en esta mañana
volvieron a pasar entonces mientras eso
se mantenga va a ser muy difícil que se
creen las condiciones del diálogo pero a
la vez el gobierno del presidente de
eeuu que está terminando y tampoco el
puede ofrecer mucho en estas condiciones
no hay un presupuesto ampliado de decir
es difícil llegar a unos niveles de
concertación
y entonces qué es lo que debe hacer la
institucionalidad en este momento de la
escalada de la violencia cómo se para
esta situación tan difícil que hemos
visto en los últimos días nadie sabe lo
que va a pasar este es un país inédito
para todos los analistas lo que son
claros con tres cosas lo primero es que
para garantizar unos mínimos de
transparencia hay que crear un libro
blanco sobre el tema de abuso policial y
derechos humanos para que toda esta
cantidad de muertes no queden impune y
para le tranquilidad a manifestantes y
familias lo segundo es que los
organizadores del paro tienen que tener
metas claras plausibles en el corto
plazo porque esto no puede durar pues
eternamente porque va a ser un gran
desgaste y llama al gobierno del
presidente iván duque a que abra su
gobierno a que por poco se pueda
establecer mediante los alcaldes
diálogos locales y los gobernadores
porque es un gobierno bastante encerrado
y también hay denuncias de
infiltraciones de guerrillas usted qué
opina
decir esto es que esto es obra de
criminales deslegitima los pedidos de la
población
y el argumento de que las
manifestaciones están infiltradas por
organizaciones criminales se utilizó en
los últimos 40 años sin embargo desde la
desmovilización de las farc pues este
argumento se ha venido mucho al suelo y
por tanto resulta a veces hasta cómico
digamos en bogotá no hay disidencia de
las farc ni nada pero es un argumento
que utiliza el gobierno yo no niego que
estos grupos estén intentando hacerlo
pero su capacidad de influencia en la
protesta está en el 1 por ciento de todo
el no el 100 por ciento de que hay de
protesta entonces es muy bajo
y lo que está pasando en la costa
atlántica donde no hay guerrilla desde
hace 20 25 años lo de bogotá sería muy
estúpido y explicarlo a partir de
organizaciones criminales pero es un
argumento que siempre ha utilizado el
gobierno nacional todos los gobiernos no
sólo es señor ávila y ya para el cierre
hay cientos de denuncias de violaciones
a los derechos humanos se hará justicia
que fue lo que pasó con las protestas en
el pasado
nosotros tenemos dos episodios muy
graves de violencia en medio de
manifestaciones una en noviembre del
2019 y otra en septiembre del año pasado
en 2020
en septiembre resultaban asesinados 12
jóvenes y todo está en la total
impunidad digamos el gran problema que
tenemos ahorita es que realmente las
fuerzas militares están salir la fuerza
pública perdón está saliendo con unos
niveles de violencia muy grande todo el
mundo sabe que lo más probable es que
todo eso quede en la impunidad